OK, this is I don't know if this is surprising
or it's not surprising, but we have another audio
leak of Donald Trump pressuring Georgia officials
to find him the votes that he needs. Donald
Trump's call to the investigator came several
days before the call with Georgia Secretary of
State Brad Raffensperger. You'll remember in the
past. We had leaked audio of Trump on the phone
with Raffensperger and others saying, I just need
eleven thousand seven hundred and eighty votes,
this new audio is from a different call where it
was a few days prior to the Raffensperger call.
Donald Trump is on the phone with Francis Watson,
who's the chief investigator in the Georgia
secretary of state's office. We are going
to listen to it. I'm realizing I don't even
have my headphone in, so let me put that
in so I can listen to it along with you.
And I'm getting all of my cables all wound
up here. Let's take a listen together.
All right, new call. OK, new call,
let's take a listen to this. Here we go.
And let's make sure we aren't muted and off we go.
All right, let's take a listen.
Yes, it's very interesting. I
won Florida and a record number Ohio and a
record Texas record. Right. Alabama by 40,
40 points. And I want everything but Georgia. I
you know, and I won Georgia. I know that by a lot.
And I won Georgia by a lot.
He says I don't know it.
And, you know, something happened
to him and something bad happened.
And I hope you doing that not because
I hope you're going back two years as
opposed to just checking. You don't want to
get shot because that would just be sort of
a signature check in anything. But if you go
back two years and if you can get to Fulton,
you're going to find things that are
going to be unbelievable. The dishonesty
will the reverse. Yes, right. Are just good
sources. Right. Sources. Fulton is the mother
lode, you know, as the expression goes, county,
right. Well, Mr. President, I want to say.
Right, I appreciate your comments.
And I can assure you that our team and
the GBI, that we're only interested in the
truth and finding and finding the information
that's based on the facts. And, you know,
we've been working 12, 16 hour days. And,
you know, we're working to Trump likes that.
Working for what exactly is not clear about it.
And so I can assure you that and I do appreciate
you all and I know that you're a very, very busy,
very important man. And I'm very honored that
you called an important work going. You do quite
quite frankly, I'm shocked and that
you would take time to do that.
But, well, he's trying to steal an
election, right? I mean, this is his last.
He thinks he needs this and very much
asked me to do the same year. And,
you know, it's just the most important
job in the country right now, because
if we win Georgia, first of all, if we win, you're
going to have to ensure you're not going to win.
Right. They're down because the people
of Georgia are so angry at what happened
to me. I won by hundreds of thousands of votes.
And so so now Trump is not even remember later.
It seems that between this call in the next call,
he he goes he here he believes he won by hundreds
of thousands. And maybe he even thinks that there
would be something done by these officials to
give him such a big win within days. Clearly, his
perspective has changed because he's just talking
about I just need eleven thousand eleven 780 and
his expectations are tempered by the next call.
And Alabama, you know, when they go because I've
won South Carolina and a record in Alabama and a
record Florida and a record, imagine calling an
official in Georgia and just bragging about your
wins in other states as if that has anything
to do with what this woman's job is here.
I won Florida by six or
seven hundred thousand votes.
I think he only won Florida by a couple
hundred thousand. Like everything is is a lie.
And exaggeration happened before with
the Republicans and with all the money
they spent years ago that these guys
go down spending a fortune and we won
Texas by a record in Texas was won by the
biggest, biggest number ever. And, you know,
it just it just an Ohio, of course, you know
that you know that that was won by nine points.
He's the president and he's bragging to
a county, a state official in Georgia
about his margins in other states. This
is the president of the United States
calling this person and bragging in this way.
I'm saying it. It's all in in Iowa and it's
it never made sense. And, you know, they
dropped ballots. They dropped all these ballots.
This year was really, really
terrible. Just a terrible thing.
Registering people to vote, getting
people out. It's horrible what she did.
I will say this. If I went home, I mean,
hopefully this will show because if you go
back two years or four years, you're going to use
a totally different signature. But but hopefully,
you know, I will when when the right
answer comes out, you'll be punished.
I mean, when you give us the right answer,
Frances, which is that I won. People will love.
You know why you made it so hard to believe
people will be praised and people will say, great,
because that's what it's about, that ability to
check into and to make it right, because everyone
knows it's wrong. It was just the way, you
know, they had people in Georgia, for instance,
that one. And I was way ahead of them and
they won because of me, they think coattails.
And so this went on for four more minutes and
it's just more Trump insisting he won. And to
her credit, Frances Watson doesn't really concede
much at all. We then just have, as a reminder,
the clips from the previous call, which the
previous call, which we actually which took
place later, the later call, which we learned
about some time ago, here's one clip from that.
The people of Georgia are angry,
the people of the country are angry.
And there's nothing wrong
with saying that, you know,
that you've recalculated because in
2000, 2006 and absentee ballots, I mean,
they're all exact numbers that were were done
by accounting firms, law firms, etc. And even
if you cut them in half, cut them in half and cut
them in half again, it's more votes than we need.
Well, Mr. President, the challenge that
you have is the data you have is wrong.
You might say we've recalculated 2200 ballots.
It's enough for us to win. And that was that was
Brad Raffensperger telling Trump that his data was
simply wrong. On that call, Trump continued making
false statements, trying to convince them to find
votes, claiming he won by hundreds of thousands,
bringing up more conspiracy theories.
I won this election by hundreds of thousands
of votes. There's no way I lost Georgia. There's
no way we won by hundreds of thousands of votes.
I'm just going by small numbers when you add them
up there many times the 11000. But but I won that
state by hundreds of thousands of votes. Now,
do you think it's possible that they shredded
ballots in Fulton County? Because that's what the
rumor is and also that Dominion took out machines,
that Dominion is really moving
fast to get rid of their.
Machinery, do you know anything about that?
Because that's illegal in Germany,
no dominion has not moved any machinery out
of Fulton County, where have they moved you?
Have they have they moved the inner parts of
the machines and replaced them with other parts?
He's you're right, I'm sure, I'm sure.
Mr. President, what about what about the what
about the ballots, the shredding of the ballots?
Have they been shredding ballots?
No, the only investigation that we have in is
that they have not been shredding any ballots.
There was an issue in Cobb County where they were
doing normal, you know, office run and getting rid
of old stuff. And we investigated that.
So Trump just desperately grasping at
straws. And then remember that in the end,
even if he had somehow flipped Georgia,
it wouldn't have made a difference because it
would not have been enough electoral votes.
Just one more clip from the old phone
call, which happened after the one we
learned about today, Trump suggesting that
this is actually bad for Georgia officials.
They might be liable if they don't find a way
for Trump to get the win to balance the corrupt.
And you're going to find that they are and which
is totally illegal. It's it's more illegal for
you than it is for them because you know what
they did and you're not reporting it. That's
you know, that's a criminal that's a criminal
offense. And, you know, you can't let that
happen. And that's that's a big risk to you
and to Ryan. Your lawyer is that's a big risk.
Well, I want to do is this I just want to find
eleven thousand seven hundred eighty votes.
So Trump, they're kind of implicitly threatening
the lawyers and officials. If you let it happen,
you could be you could be criminally liable.
So a totally criminal bully president. Another
recording from another conversation coming out
almost two months post Trump leaving office. What
will we know in another month? What will we know
in a month after that? What we are learning is
that the authoritarians who tried to overthrow the
election were far more brazen than we previously
thought. I don't think we've come even close to
hearing at all yet. And when all is said and done,
the biggest evidence is probably yet to come.
They're getting access to emails and texts, which
will give us the context and planning like this.
These two calls, they don't just happen. There's
likely a paper trail about how this call came
to be and about the intentions for these calls.
And we may eventually learn about that.
We'll have more coverage of this on the show,
Instagram The David Pakman Show and make sure
you're following me on Instagram at David Pakman.